what do you remember about being on
Smallville I had a great time what do
you remember I mean we did kind of an
iconic scene of putting the baby Julian
Sands and I putting the baby into the
rocket to like go bring it down to and
then with everyone was so kind on your
set do you remember that I love them all
it was a family it was just sure it
really was there wasn't anybody I didn't
like working with no and they were so
sweet to me and very you know I felt
very well that's what it's about my
friend Kathleen wilhoid says she says
being a guest star or a guest director
is like being the girlfriend at your
boyfriend's family Thanksgiving
okay it's like